that truly has completely blown my
slicked hair back from emily Blunt's big
win to host megan mullaly's odd sex kit
yeah i want you to get a child give it
to you TT is taking a look at the 2019
screen actor Guild Awards best worst and
weirdest moment after years of
unemployment Jeffry Owens is back to
work and received a round of applause
from his peers to kick off the shows I
am an actor monologues instead of
switching careers like the same person I
took a job at a local Trader Joe's to
see if I could hang in there with my
career and it's actually worked out
pretty well
it was a sweet / marvelous missus Mazal
taking TV top honors with best ensemble
Rachel for Best Actress and Tony for
Best Actor in a comedy series but things
got weird between presenters Megan and
Alec Baldwin before Tony
accepted his hardware you're not wearing
your wedding ring I make it under this
dress and the actor goes to give me that
give it to me we all felt the excitement
when this is us 1 for Best ensemble in a
Drama Series the 15 after ensemble of
this is us
second wind and Emily's heartwarming
acceptance speech that left her hubby
teary-eyed in the crowd
you are a stunning filmmaker I'm so
lucky to be with you and to have done
this film with you
Sandra Oh gave an impassioned speech
after winning for killing Eve thanking
her fellow actors for their endless
support over the years
I want to thank alfre woodard wait in
1997 she whispered in my ear I'm so
proud of you out there we fight the same
fight Jamie Foxx in 2006 pulled me aside
and he said keep going then Megan called
out the historical lack of dynamic roles
for women Glenn Close played a wife so
that's new Melissa McCarthy portrayed a
woman who repeatedly apologizes and SR
forgiveness but she did list all of the
things Hollywood finally got right in
2018
they cast black people in black panther
Asian people and crazy rich Asians and a
green book in green book you know you
know there was some executives saying um
arguably the best moment of the night
black panther taking the night's top
honor for Best ensemble in a motion
picture Chadwick Boseman stepped out in
true to chala fashion delivering a
speech fit for a king
has it actually changed the way this
industry works how it sees us and my
answer to that is to be young gifted and
black did it change the industry I know
that you can't have a black panther now
without a to awning and queen mother
Angela Bassett sold ET Black Panther to
is coming back with a bang
everybody back for the sequel
yes yes everyone on baby boy yes yes yes
we didn't technically see you go into
the og including Michael
[Music]